das ist das günstigste smarteste und
atemberaubende Wohnbauprojekt dass die
Welt so bislang noch nicht gesehen hat
mir verschlägt ist seitdem wir hier in
die Stadt gekommen sind die Sprache
atemberaubende Traumstrände reihen sich
an Grün bepflanzte Luxushotels mit golf
resorts und Hochgeschwindigkeitszügen
fühlt sich an als wenn man in der Stadt
in der man eigentlich nicht sein sollte
alles für eine traumoase die das Leben
in Südostasien revolutionieren sollte
wie kann es also sein dass 100
Milliarden Dollar in eine Stadt fließen
in der nahezu jeder Shop geschlossen ist
jede Straße wie leer gefegt und jede mal
verlassen ist wie kann es sein dass sie
einfach niemand leben will und warum
wird alles dafür getan dass hier um
jeden Preis der scheint wird je länger
wir nach Antworten gesucht haben desto
mehr bröckelte die Fassade dieser
konstruierten Traumwelt das ist keine
spielsimulation das ist echt das ist die
Geisterstadt von Malaysia namens forest
city
[Musik]
ich bin noch mal leise geflogen um
herauszufinden wie viel von dem war es
was sie in Werbefilm versprechen ich
möchte die futuristischen Luxushotels
Strände und Ideen mit meinen eigenen
Augen sehen und selber erleben wie die
Zukunft aussehen soll 40 km entfernt vom
Stadtkern Singapurs liegt also das
Milliarden schwere Immobilienprojekt
Forrest City schon von weitem konnte man
die bewachsenden bodenhäuser sehen und
nicht nur das jede Gelegenheit wird
dafür genutzt um die Stadt zu grün wie
möglich wirken zu lassen
[Musik]
auf dem Weg rein in die Stadt begegneten
uns vielleicht eine Handvoll Autos und
das was wir im Vorfeld über die Stadt
und ihre Einwohner gehört haben sollte
sich bewahrheiten vorbei an Pools die
für Familien mit Kindern gemacht waren
und solchen die es einmal werden sollten
über zu leergefegten Straßen auf denen
es sich beim Blick auf die Häuser so
anfühlte als ob alle Menschen die Stadt
schlagartig verlassen hätten fast wie in
dem Film niemand bis auf eine Handvoll
Arbeitern und Sicherheitsleuten und
mitten im Traumparadies liegt eine ganz
bestimmte Halle die das Herzstück dieser
Traumwelt bildet eine Halle namens sales
Art Gallery ja geht's darum eigentlich
die restlichen Wohnung zu verkaufen es
gibt Modelle es ist riesengroß und alles
super sauber wie sonst auch alles hier
aber es ist niemand da der irgendwas
kaufen will haben auf dem Weg hierhin
sechs sieben Leute gesehen aber hier ist
nichts los
gar nichts also wir haben hier vorne den
Bereich Sales Gallery da befinden wir
uns gerade jetzt hier weiter das ist
tatsächlich alles gebaut hier
successful Handover an den Hotelbesitzer
da sind wir gerade ein quartiert da
unten ist der Pool der existiert auch
dieser gesamte Rest alles was hier rüber
geht all das dieses Gebäude das noch mal
viel höher ist als als das höchste was
jetzt gerade steht das ist alles nicht
gebaut in dem Modell sind ganz viele
Boote und Yachten eingezeichnet wenn man
wahrscheinlich davon ausgegangen ist
dass wenn Leute hochpreisige Wohnung
kaufen die auch irgendwelche Yachten
oder teure Boote an der an der Küste
entlang fahren aber davon haben wir bis
dato noch nichts gesehen und an ganz
vielen Häusern steht einfach dran dass
die Sound sind natürlich überhaupt nicht
der Wahrheit entspricht also gar nicht
eigentlich hört es sich zu schön an um
wahr zu sein glaubt man den Berichten
von den Gründern vom forest City
entsteht im Süden Malaysias in
Blickweite von Singapur eine smarthoase
die weltweit seinesgleichen sucht
schätzungsweise sollen durch die Stadt
220.000 neue Jobs geschaffen werden und
über 700.000 Einwohner Platz finden das
hat mit normalen Bauprojekten nichts
mehr zu tun im Grunde kann man sagen
dass die Gründer von forest City den
Erfolg des Projektes auf drei Säulen
Stützen zum einen geht's um günstige
Immobilien und zwar so günstig dass wenn
man nur ansatzweise in Singapur arbeitet
und lebt nicht drumherum kommt
mindestens einmal drüber nachzudenken
nach City zu ziehen Nummer 2 heißt
Sonderwirtschaftszone Island da oder
einfacher Steueroase und bedeutet im
Umkehrschluss ist werden
Steuervergünstigung geschaffen um große
Firmen und Menschen mit viel Geld
anzulocken und zuletzt soll modernste
Verkehrsinfrastruktur forest City zum
neuen Knotenpunkt machen der den
Transport von Menschen und waren auf der
gesamten Halbinsel vereinfacht und genau
diese Infrastruktur die mehrere
hunderttausende Menschen davon
überzeugen sollte in die Hyper moderne
Stadt zu ziehen beginnt im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes zu bröckeln forest City
war quasi als win win Situation gedacht
die Stadt wird zu einer wirklichen
Alternative zu den unfassbaren Liebenden
Singapur Malaysia bekommt ein Luxus
Aushängeschild und setzt mit dem
Bauprojekt ein weltweites Daten und zu
guter Letzt China und der Grund dafür
liegt eigentlich auf der Hand dazu aber
gleich mehr man muss sich nur mal
vorstellen mit welcher Euphorie Menschen
dort Wohnungen gekauft haben der Sales
Gallery vor der Fotowand standen und
dachten sie hätten einen richtig guten
Deal gemacht dort in forest City im
großen Stil passiert in Deutschland bei
uns genauso im kleinen ich würde
schätzen bei ca 80% von euch die meisten
von euch zahlen nämlich viel zu viel für
ihren Strom und Gasvertrag
ärgern sich am Ende weil sie das Geld an
anderer Stelle viel besser gebrauchen
können und damit das nie wieder passiert
gibt es wechselt den Partner des
heutigen Videos wechselt ist ein
premiumwechselservice der jedes Jahr für
euch den besten und Mark gerechtesten
Strom und gasriegen und das beste ohne
dass ihr etwas dafür tun müsst wie viele
dabei einsparen können findet ihr super
easy mit dem briefrechner mit wenigen
Klicks heraus dafür gebt ihr einfach
eure Postleitzahl ein mit wie viel
Leuten im Haushalt lebt und wie viel ihr
ungefähr verbraucht und wechselpilot
weiß direkt welche Anbieter Strom und
Gas zu euch nach Hause liefern auf Basis
der Postleitzahl erkennt wechselpilot
dann euren Grundversorger wenn ich ganz
genau wissen wollt könnt ihr aus der
Liste eurem Versorger aussuchen und eure
Konditionen eintragen die findet ihr in
eurem Vertrag oder der letzten
Abrechnung ihr bekommt jetzt immer eine
Auswahl aus drei neuen Tarifen die
besser sind als der aktuelle die Tarif
den die wechselexperten auch selber
wählen würden eine grüne Alternative und
den günstigsten ihr checkt die Tarife
und entscheidet dann dass die beste
Option für euch ist jetzt weiß
wechselpilot was euch wichtig ist und
optimiert anhand dieser Informationen
jedes Jahr aufs Neue euren Vertrag ohne
dass ihr nur ein Finger kommen müsst
oder irgendein Formular auszufüllen und
jeder weiß keine Post ist gut Post und
deswegen übernimmt Wechsel Pilot während
der gesamten Vertragslaufzeit die
Kommunikation mit eurem Versorgung und
steht euch als direkte Ansprechpartner
für alle Fragen und Anliegen bereit und
dem was ihr spart also nur das was ihr
weniger ausgeht gehen 80% an euch und
20% für den Service an wechselt das ist
ziemlich schwer es gibt nichts nerviges
als in einem vollkommen übertreiben
Vertrag zu hängen und Monat für Monat
dabei zusehen zu müssen wie das Geld aus
dem Fenster fliegt obwohl man es
eigentlich an anderer Stelle besser
gebrauchen könnte also jetzt den ersten
Link in der Videobeschreibung aus und
nutzt Dave für 20 € Rabatt auf eure
nächsten Wechsel und ich rate euch macht
es wirklich es wird wieder kälter holt
euch einen besseren Deal und geht dieses
Thema einmal an und habe immer Ruhe
vielen Dank an wechselpilot fürs möglich
machen dieses Projektes und euch viel
Spaß weiter mit dem Video
aber um zu verstehen warum dieses
Megaprojekt immer mehr Risse bekommt
müssen wir einen Blick hinter die
Fassade werfen denn hier geht es nicht
nur um einen spaßiges Zukunftsprojekt
von ein paar Menschen mit viel zu viel
Geld forest City ist durchsetzt von
Korruptionsvorwürfen umweltverstößen und
dem Einfluss von einem der mächtigsten
Länder der Welt China
durch die in 2006 extra eingerichtete
Sonderwirtschaftszone Iskandar versuchte
die malaysische Regierung eine
investorenfreundliche Zone zu errichten
darunter fehlen auch der Bau eines Uni
Campus der Ausbau der nächstgrößeren
Stadt Johann oder der Ausbau eines
Containerhafens alles wurde darauf
ausgerichtet einen neuen Big Player
neben Singapur aufzuziehen forest City
sollte dafür das Aussehen geschickt
werden doch die Firmen kamen nicht
das hier hätte mal die fußstreet sein
sollen so sieht das dann aus
Riesengeschäft
leer mit Baumaterialien drin
[Musik]
und das Monat das riecht überall schon
etwas
etwas nass und dann konnten wir doch
noch einen Shop finden der geöffnet
hatte hi
okay Einkaufsladen jetzt hier
mit Gemüse
Getränken bisschen Einrichtungen da
vorne sind auch Teller und so
Wasserkocher scheint so als wäre es der
eine Laden der überlebt hätte weil er
eben einfach alles hat und als wir
gerade zahlen wollten entdeckte der Shop
Besitzer unsere Kamera
ja
die Leute finden das übelst nice dass
wir hier sind er hat gesagt ja wir als
Chinesen wir mögen das uns Freunde zu
machen und deswegen die beiden drinks
for free krank also ich fange an das
hier richtig zu mögen ich habe jetzt
nicht das Gefühl dass
ich hier jemals hinziehen würde
aber
das ist schon cool
die Zielgruppe von forest City ist
wirklich unübersehbar Wegweiser
Speisekarten Werbetafeln egal wo man
hinguckt es ist alles auf Chinesisch und
schaut mal näher hin wer hinter diesem
Projekt die Fäden zieht dann ist das
nicht wirklich verwunderlich hinter all
diesen Spektakel steht nämlich eine
Firma namens country Garden Holding
Chinas größte Baufirma und seit 15
Jahren in der Fortune Global 500
gelistet mit mehreren tausend Projekten
in mehr als 300 chinesischen Städten
dominiert die heutigen mit 40 Milliarden
US-Dollar in Jahresumsatz den gesamten
chinesischen Bausektor genau diese Firma
hält 60% am Projekt City und hat somit
die absolute Mehrheit wenn es um
wirklich wichtige Entscheidung geht über
Jahre hinweg bauten sich wegen Forrest
City immer mehr Spannung zwischen
Malaysia und Country Garden auf 20 18
knalltest schließlich 70% der
Vorverkäufe der Wohnung wurden von
Festland Chinesen getätigt und die
Zahlen sagten nicht Malaysia Sorge es
entstehe eine chinesische Enklave auf
malaysischen Staatsgebiet auf das
Malaysia irgendwann keinen Einfluss mehr
hat quasi eine gated community für
Wirtschaft Logistik und Tourismus also
zog Malaysia die Handbremse und stoppte
jegliche Verkäufe an ausländische Käufer
und nicht nur china hat wohl ein
Interesse an dem Projekt je länger man
sich mit forest City beschäftigt desto
öfter taucht der Name Ibrahim Ismael von
Joe auf der Sultan des Gebiets und einer
der neuen traditionellen Monarchen
Malaysias der aber größtenteils eher
durch kuriose Entscheidungen auf wie zum
Beispiel die Verlegung des Wochenendes
vom Samstag und Sonntag auf Freitag und
Samstag oder sich Wunschkennzeichen wie
w1n für Win oder www.1 für umgerechnet
100000 € sichert und weil die meisten
Reichen und Mächtigen Menschen am
liebsten noch mehr Macht und Reichtum
haben wollen entschied er sich das
Projekt naja sagen wir mal zu fördern
und das nicht zu knapp nicht besonders
verwunderlich wenn man bedenkt dass er
mehr als Eigentümer der Firma Esplanade
88 ist welche die 40% an forest sind die
besitzt die nicht zu country Garden
gehören man sagt über ihn er sei der
Schlüssel aktuell der dieses Projekt
überhaupt erst möglich gemacht hat es
wird von einer ungeschriebenen Regel
berichtet dass alle wichtigen Entscheid
ungen der stillschweigenden Zustimmung
des Sultans bedürfen als Teil einer
unsichtbaren aber unbitterlichen
Machtstruktur ihm wurde vorgeworfen
Verfahren für country Garden Holdings zu
beschleunigen und wichtige Umwelttests
zu verschleiern ein Fluss auf das
Projekt zu nehmen und ja das Projekt ist
nicht fertig aber es stehen einige
Häuser deswegen kommt die Frage auf wie
lebt man hier
okay
hier geht's rein also zur rechten Seite
haben wir ein Badezimmer
Strom ist abgestellt hier ein kleines
Badezimmer bodentiefe Dusche geht's hier
weiter in den Wohnbereich eingerichtet
Vorsteuer Samsung Waschmaschine Küche
ist drin Kühlschrank Fernseher hängt
Wohnbereich mit Sofa Klimaanlage ist
eingebaut also die Sachen sind voll
ausgestattet dann geht's hier ach du
scheiße
die Seite haben wir noch gar nicht
gesehen
jetzt hier auf dem Balkon nicht nur
stehen hier noch weitere Häuser die mir
noch gar nicht aufgefallen waren sondern
wir haben auch Aussicht auf das
Labyrinth das hier angelegt wurde einen
riesen offenen Parkplatz eine
Fußballstadion 50 m Schwimmbecken
irgendwas das aussieht wie ein
Verwaltungsgebäude und einfach wieder
ein zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben
zwölf riesige Wohngebäude
[Musik]
großes Bett Meerblick
auch wieder Klimaanlage und hier gibt es
noch ein zweites master bedroom und
wieder am Balkon und wieder mehr Blick
krank
die Frage die sich nach diesen Bildern
stellt ist warum will hier verdammt noch
mal niemand leben die Mieten sind im
Vergleich zu Singapur sportbelicht die
Qualität top und die Lebensqualität
könnte wirklich schlimmer sein nach ein
bisschen Recherche wurde klar dass es
mehrere Gründe haben kann der Peak des
Projekts sollte während der Jahre 2020
und 2021 sein corona-pandemie erwischte
auch mal leise sehr schwer und trug
vermutlich dazu bei dass viele Käufer
Absprachen und Investoren ihr Interesse
zurückgezogen gleichzeitig waren die
Kosten für malaysische Bürger von Anfang
an viel zu hoch for the city wurde also
nur zu einer Alternative zu Singapur für
die die sich eh schon leisten konnten
dies waren offensichtlich größtenteils
Festland Chinesen die der malaysischen
Regierung ein Dorn im Auge waren und bis
heute sind zuletzt ist die versprochene
Infrastruktur bei weitem nicht das was
in dem Broschüren versprochen wurde
marode Brücken fehlende
Hochgeschwindigkeitszüge und ein
Verkehrsnetz das nicht mit dem Aussehen
kaputt zu vergleichen ist ein Schatten
seiner selbst was bleibt also jetzt am
Tagesende übrig irgendwie in den
mulmiges Gefühl sie erlebt habe ist eine
Stadt die Buchstaben gebaut von Beginn
um jeden Preis zum Erfolg verdammt war
die Messlatte wurde einfach unfassbar
hochgelegt die Immobiliengesellschaft
kann regarden ist bemüht bei jeder
Gelegenheit zu betonen das forest City
ein Projekt über 20 Jahre sein außerdem
stünden weitere Festivals an und es gäbe
viel mehr auf das sich zu freuen gibt
aber ich frage mich für wen wenn niemand
dort leben will das krampfhafte
Festhalten an der Idee von forest City
liegt für mich eher wie ein Schauspiel
bei dem aber niemand im Publikum sitzt
es ist völlig absurd und dieses Buffet
beim Abendessen wird symptomatisch dafür
das hat sich alles okay angefühlt bis zu
diesem Moment wir sind in dem einzigen
Hotel das wirklich geöffnet hat
und es ist niemand beim Abendessen wir
sind die absolut einzigen Gäste und hier
steht ein Buffet im Prinzip ist dieses
Buffet nur für uns und die Sachen sehen
super gut aus da war noch kein Löffel
drin das ist antutscht der einzige was
man hört ist die
Ventilatoren oben die nicht ganz
runterlaufen
zwei Angestellte hier mit uns und
sind hi tausend Quadratmeter Speisesaal
verrückt
was am Ende bleibt ist die Erkenntnis
dass man mit viel Geld scheinbar jede
Traumwelt bauen kann das aber nicht
bedeutet dass diese Traumwelt
automatisch irgendwie interessiert
vielen Dank fürs zusehen dass mich gerne
in den Kommentaren wissen ob ihr mehr
solcher Videos sehen wollt wir sehen uns
nächste Woche wieder
[Musik]